[Music]  meg Ryan is the ultimate bikini babe Wow  I never thought of it that way the 56  year old actress was spotted making a  splash in the Mediterranean while living  the vacation life in Portofino Italy  check out Meg rockin a tiny black bikini  top and black and blue board shorts with  her toned arms and abs on full display  the blonde beauty went makeup free for  her day at sea and completed the casual  look with tossin tresses before her boat  ride and eye witness spotted Meg taking  a stroll through town for some retail  therapy and ice cream to cool off from  the heat the wind Harry Met Sally  actress isn't the only star enjoying a  summer getaway sure are sorry /  Sleepless in Seattle co-star Tom Hanks  appeared to be spending some quality  time in Italy with his wife Rita Wilson  and 28 year old son check  [Music]